nous sommes aujourd'hui au rectorat de
l'académie de Versailles à mes côtés
Ginette koh-linka bonjour
alors vous êtes survivante des camps de
concentration et d'extermination
d'auschwitch birkeno aujourd'hui cette
salle vient d'être inaugurée à votre nom
on en parlera dans quelques instants
juste avant je vous propose d'écouter
l'interview express de la reprise
académique de Versailles Charline Avenel
[Musique]
le 8 mars dernier on nous avons fait
voter les personnels du rectorat sur
plusieurs noms pour donner à cette salle
qui est la salle majeure de du rectorat
de Versailles celle où nous faisons
toutes les réunions pour pouvoir lui
donner le nom d'une femme et moi je
souhaitais que ce soit une femme et une
femme qui a un lien avec la transmission
et donc j'ai proposé parmi les lots les
noms
sur lesquels faire voter le nombre de
Ginette colinka
[Musique]
elle nous raconte à la fois l'horreur et
puis ce qu'elle nous raconte aussi c'est
son puissant désir de vivre d'être
heureuse depuis que qu'elle est sortie
des camps et elle nous donne aussi une
leçon évidemment c'est là tout son
propos avec les jeunes à propos qui vise
à lutter contre la haine contre le
racisme contre l'antisémitisme et qui
apprend beaucoup pour vivre en somme
[Musique]
c'est difficile aujourd'hui dans les
écoles de France de parler de ce moment
de la Shoah c'est difficile parce que
les élèves sont sensibles on perd
progressivement la mémoire et donc plus
que jamais c'est nécessaire et il faut
s'appeler à cette tâche de transmission
de mémoire il faut s'y appeler pour ne
pas oublier le passé parce que le passé
est clair sur le présent et sur l'avenir
[Musique]
nous sommes actuellement dans cette
salle qui porte votre nom qu'est-ce que
ça fait d'avoir une salle justement qui
porte votre nom ça me semble tellement
grand que j'y crois pas ça me semble
trop grand trop important pourquoi moi
mais pourquoi pas les autres elles
auront fait elles ont souffert comme moi
et il y en a aussi qui parle comme moi
alors j'avoue franchement que tous ces
honneurs c'est agréable mais d'un autre
côté c'est excessif et ça me gêne et
vous aviez dit tout à l'heure que
parfois vous vous rendiez en classe et
vous demandez au plus jeune de moins de
15 ans de se lever quand j'ai demandé
aux jeunes de se lever c'est parce que
pour leur prouver que les paroles une
lecture c'est rien
on écoute on lit mais on sera pas compte
mais quand vous avez une classe de
troisième où vous dites aux élèves ceux
qui ont moins de 15 ans levez-vous et
que vous voyez toute la classe qui se
lève et je leur dis
on vous aurait tué alors là oui il se
rendent compte vous aviez également
mentionné tout à l'heure que pendant
près de 40 ans vous n'aviez pas parlé de
ce passé exact 40 ans un peu plus ça
peut voir ça je sais pas non non mais
moi je voulais pas en parler quand j'ai
appris que la guerre était finie
la première première chose que j'ai
pensé
Ginette tu raconteras pas ton histoire
t'embêtera pas les gens à raconter ce
que tu as vécu pas parce que je voulais
pas dire que j'avais t'aider parce que
je ne voulais pas embêter les gens à
entendre toujours la même histoire pour
ne plus que ça se reproduise quel
message aujourd'hui vous souhaitez faire
passer
accepter l'autre comme il est avec ses
qualités avec ses défauts avec sa
couleur de peau avec sa religion
pourquoi que je vous empêcherai de vivre
vous n'êtes pas juif vous noir alors
vous êtes bon à rien pas juive et noir
vous êtes un être humain bien merci
Madame colinka c'est très gentil de
m'avoir accordé cette interview il y a
pas de quoi